hi thank you very much for the talk and
for speaking to us today
uh my question is about how often in
your videos and articles you talk about
america being
the best country in the world and i'm
wondering whether that contradicts your
belief in both economic freedom and the
right to life for the unborn because
based on indices i've seen for economic
freedom
for example america is um i think 17th
on cato in
institutes and decks of freedom 12th for
heritage foundations economic freedom
index
and for right to life for the unborn
it's i think one of only seven countries
that permits uh
third trimester abortions so how would
you give like a factual
defense for america being not just one
of the best but the best country in the
world
sure okay so the so here's how i would
here's how i put it the best baseball
team
in baseball is the washington nationals
they won the world series okay
that does not mean that does not mean
that every player on their team is the
best at his position
right the united states is the best
overall if you could choose anywhere
in the world to grow up to have a chance
at success
the united states would be the place we
have the most robust economy we have
freedoms that you don't have another
place in the world freedom of speech
freedom of religion freedom of assembly
we have constitutional freedoms
guaranteed right all these things are
wondrous things that
not only are unique but also undergird
the rest of western civilization i mean
again as the united states falls asleep
as everybody else
that does not mean that i think that our
generalized abortion policy is the best
on earth nor does it mean i think that
our generalized tax policy
is the best on earth now it is also true
that the economic
freedom index very often like that
particular study tends to deal with
regulatory climate the united states is
regulatory climate with particular
with regard to foreign investment for
example uh is is weak and needs to be
strengthened
it's why we all are looking to to make
it better right america can get better
in a variety of ways
but what i mean by that is america is
the least racist country on earth it is
the place with the most opportunity on
earth it has done the most good for the
most people in america and around the
globe
america is is the most rights-based
country
on earth it has the best creed that has
ever been created by man
in the history of man it seems like a
pretty good start